[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de Demain à la Une au menu
aujourd'hui l'Ukraine l'Ukraine qui ne
pourra jamais oublier ce 24 février 2022
date à laquelle la Russie a lancé une
invasion à grande échelle de son voisin
dans la seconde partie on parlera de la
présidentielle du 25 février au Nigeria
sécurité économie on évoquera les enjeux
de ce scrutin dans le pays le plus
peuplé d'Afrique
mais avant cela donc l'Ukraine à
quelques jours de ce premier triste
anniversaire cette tentative d'invasion
totale du pays par la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine le chef du Kremlin voulait
rapidement prendre la capitale et les
grandes villes une guerre éclair en
somme en vain 12 mois plus tard c'est
désormais une sanglante guerre de
position qui se joue et cela pourrait
durer encore de longs mois pour
m'accompagner notre correspondant en
Ukraine Gulliver Craig bonjour Gulliver
vous intervenez depuis Kiev bonjour à
vous aussi Cyril Payen bonjour vous êtes
grand reporter ici à France 24 merci à
vous deux d'être là je me tourne tout
d'abord vers vous Gulliver quel bilan
peut-on dresser aujourd'hui notamment
dans le don basse où vous êtes rendu
plusieurs fois pour France 24
malheureusement ce n'est vraiment pas le
moment de dresser un boulot bilan et
surtout dans le don de base la Russie
n'a absolument pas abandonné son
objectif de prendre le contrôle de la
totalité de cette région et la prix
certaine partie du don-basse notamment
dans la région de l'Ouest et puis la
ville portuaire très importante de Mario
Paul au printemps mais les combats
continuent absolument dans le Dondas ce
qui n'est pas le cas pour le moment du
moins pour qui avait sa région si au
début de la guerre les Russes semblaient
avoir l'intention de prendre la capitale
ukrainienne les Ukrainiens ont fait
preuve d'une détermination à résister
qui a vraiment je pense peut-être autant
la détermination que la prouesse
militaire dans cette résistance a
vraiment surpris presque tout le monde
même ici à Kiev j'avoue que les premiers
jours de la guerre peu de gens pensaient
que l'Ukraine allait pouvoir résister de
cette manière on a appris bien des
choses sur les forces armées
ukrainiennes mais aussi il faut le dire
sur les forces armées russes qui ont
clairement commis des assez surprenante
mais pour dresser un bilan de ce conflit
ce n'est pas le moment tout continue
tout est encore en flux si ce n'est que
de compter le nombre de morts de
personnes déplacées les millions de vies
qui ont été bouleversés ce n'est pas le
moment de faire un bidon le message est
bien passé si côté ukrainien est capable
de résister au feu russe et grâce bien
sûr aux armes occidentales Cyril volody
mersilenski en veut plus et le plus
rapidement possible les chars c'est fait
pas encore les avions c'est côté
ukrainien bien sûr le nerf de la guerre
sans ces armes impossible de résister
bonif Florence et c'est déterminant et
surtout à cette période importante
évidemment ça fait un an on le sait
cette opération militaire spéciale selon
le diktat russe qui devait durer trois
jours ça va faire un an mais le temps ne
va pas nécessairement jouer en faveur de
ceux qui ont surpris Gulliver le disait
parfaitement avec cette formidable
contre-offensive
ukrainienne le temps long n'est pas le
bon et là aujourd'hui même à la
conférence de Munich le président
français le chancelier allemand on dit
nous allons nous installer dans long et
paradoxalement velody Merzer Zelinski
lui plait pour la vitesse il a besoin de
vitesse de de soutien aérien d'avions et
surtout que la communauté internationale
qui est un peu piétiné qui est un peu
flottante au début du conflit sur savoir
quoi faire de discuter avec Vladimir
Poutine s'engager auprès des Ukrainiens
et bien doit honorer ces promesses ces
promesses d'envoi de chars de plus de
d'artillerie il y a eu le le fait que
les Américains donnent ce système de
défense patriote on se rappelle ce
voyage très très symbolique de zeninski
aux États-Unis pour obtenir ce système
anti-missiles mais c'est un gain de
temps l'armée ukrainienne et l'Ukraine
dans son entièreté gagne du temps sur
une machine russe et avec l'aide
benasses sans doute une prochaine
offensive de très grande envergure de la
part de Moscou et c'est ma prochaine
question Gulliver les forces russes sont
beaux ne pas avoir atteint leur objectif
elles ont gagné néanmoins du terrain on
se pose beaucoup de questions bien sûr
les Russes sont-ils capables de lancer
une nouvelle offensive une nouvelle
mobilisation et si oui quand
d'une certaine point de vue la nouvelle
offensive a déjà commencé les Russes ont
pris l'initiative sur le front de l'Est
et attaque Manon à plusieurs endroits
depuis le 1er août cette bataille
acharnée pour la ville de pakmouth et
ton cours mais maintenant il y a
plusieurs autres points chauds dans
l'est du pays mais pour le moment même
si les Ukrainiens avouent qu'ils sont
sous une pression très intense et que
les Russes ont en quelque sorte
maintenant l'initiative on ne parle pas
en ce moment de contre-offensive
ukrainienne mais plutôt même de
contre-offensives russes si vous voulez
avec les Russes qui essayent de
reprendre du territoire dans la région
de harkis notamment qui avait été repris
par les Ukrainiens au mois de septembre
pour le moment les Russes n'affichent
pas vraiment de succès très notable il y
a quelques jours la rumeur et même de
l'aveu de certains soldats sur place
qu'il avouait ouvertement devant les
journalistes ont pensé que backmout
allait tomber que les Russes allaient
enfin réussir à prendre cette ville de
batbout maintenant cela semble beaucoup
moins certains les Ukrainiens
officiellement déterminé à garder le
contrôle de la ville Prigogine le chef
de Wagner ce groupe de mercenaires
lui-même avoué que cela va prendre très
longtemps à vendre prendre backmout
certains pensent que il voulait que
pac-mouton des Russes avant
l'anniversaire de l'invasion a grande
échelle maintenant cela semble moins que
certains mais ceux qui inquiète beaucoup
les Ukrainiens en ce moment c'est le
nombre d'avions de chasse qui semble
s'accumuler juste l'autre côté de la
frontière en Russie et on se demande si
les Russes peut-être vont commencer à
utiliser de nouvelles tactiques à savoir
faire une usage beaucoup plus importante
l'aviation ce qui n'avait pas fait
jusqu'à présent dans cette guerre aussi
parce que les
Ukrainiens ont des missiles solaires qui
peuvent abattre des avions russes mais
maintenant certains analystes pensent
que les Russes ont décidé que ils
peuvent sacrifier un certain nombre
d'avions de chasse pour poursuivre des
offensives aériennes de tellement grandi
en verdure que cela pourrait leur
permettre de
des résultats un peu plus
impressionnants cyril a un petit pas de
côté avec vous c'est de dire en Ukraine
c'est bien sûr une guerre
multidimensionnelle et une bataille qui
fait particulièrement rache et celle de
l'information plutôt de la
désinformation on est en plein
effectivement dans la cette guerre
informée qui est une lutte d'influence
d'importance c'est ce qui est saisissant
d'ailleurs si on compare avec le début
de la guerre où nous étions notamment la
bataille de Kiev à Herpin boucha des
villes dont on attend on connaît hélas
les bilans effroyables c'est qu'il y
avait une liberté absolue c'est-à-dire
que les Ukrainiens étaient certes un peu
dépassé mais les journalistes pouvaient
se pouvaient se rendre où il voulait on
se on était à bout de chat au front donc
tout a changé au fil des mois avec un
contrôle strict d'abord sur le terrain
territorial de la presse quel qu'elle
soit un énorme contrôle et on est
vraiment dans la volonté de contrôle et
puis il va vous le disiez cette guerre
de je dirais presque de propagande quoi
que le mot soit pas approprié dans le
sens d'un qui a envahit un autre pays un
autre qui réagit un envahisseur mais ça
ressemble un peu la propagande si l'on
compare les chiffres quotidiens que nous
livre soit Moscou soit Kiev c'était
Phara de voir le nombre de pertes c'est
souvent mutuelle par 10 ou par 100 ça
prêterait même à sourire si c'était pas
évidemment le révélateur d'une situation
extrêmement tragique mais on est
vraiment dans une guerre de de
déclaration de chiffres et ça fait
partie évidemment de cette guerre
informationnelle qui fait aussi rage un
des deux côtés depuis maintenant un an
Gulliver vous l'avez brièvement évoqué
tout à l'heure cette armée russe elle
est désormais aux pôlée officiellement
par le groupe Wagner c'est le cas
darkmout dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure à quoi peut servir demain Wagner
en Ukraine on sait que ces derniers
temps le ton est monté entre son
fondateur if Yenni Prigogine et l'armée
russe qu'il accuse notamment de lenteur
à des ambitions mais les analystes de la
Russie qui comprennent bien mieux la
situation en Russie que moi semble dire
que il a peu de chances vraiment de
peser à l'avenir en Russie aussi parce
que même si la Russie arrive à prendre
finalement un jour au bac mood ce ne
sera pas du tout le triomphe qu'il avait
envie d'afficher n'avait envie de
montrer que les combattants de Wagner
étaient beaucoup plus efficaces que
l'armée régulière russe et que son
pouvoir en quelque sorte serait augmenté
du fait de ces succès à bakkmouth il n'a
pas emporté les succès qu'il voulait et
Wagner a subi des pertes absolument
extraordinaires le conflit et les
tactiques employés sont comparés au
tactique de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
la Première Guerre mondiale pardon c'est
vraiment une guerre de tranchée où était
soldats en très grand nombre sont
envoyés uniquement en réalité pour
repérer les positions ukrainiennes ils
sont envoyés là pour être
tuer au bain mot les pertes parmi les
personnes que Wagner a recruté dans les
prisons en Russie sont de l'autre de
10000 et ça c'est vraiment l'estimation
le plus conservatrice que j'ai entendu
Cyril on essaye de se projeter aussi
dans cette émission cette guerre elle
peut elle va durer encore de loin oui on
est dans le temps long on voit pas dans
l'état actuel des choses des positions
des protagonistes qu'il y ait de l'année
négociation possible les
contre-offensives ukrainiennes ont
tellement marqué le coup qu'il est
évident évidemment impossible et les
présidents zinninski le répètent à
l'envie pas de négociation à ce stade et
Moscou continue cette marche en avant
cette fuite en avant je dirais en
employant évidemment les mercenaires les
supplétifs de de Wagner mais oui on est
dans le temps long les chanceler
occidental l'ont parfaitement compris
les alliés de l'Ukraine l'ont compris le
problème c'est que ça coûte beaucoup
évidemment en logistique puis beaucoup
en nomme ce que disait Gulliver on est
vraiment dans un paradigme de première
de guerre de tranchée la Première Guerre
mondiale avec son lot c'est incroyable
avec une intensité de conflit qu'on
pensait dont on pensait vraiment avoir
tourné la page donc oui on est dans un
temps très long qui sait à qui va
profiter ce temps long c'est en tout cas
pas certainement selon beaucoup
d'analystes militaires en faveur des
Ukrainiens vu l'hiver il nous reste une
minute quels sont les perspectives de
paix selon vous les perspectives de
paient vous savez les Ukrainiens sont
vraiment déterminés à regagner le
contrôle de tous leurs territoires et on
a Joe Biden le président américain qui a
dit que les États-Unis soutiendront
l'Ukraine pour autant de temps que cela
va prendre et en même temps le chef des
armées américaines Marc Millet qui dit
que il sera très difficile de chasser
les forces russes de tous les
territoires
Ukrainiens actuellement
occupé alors il y a en réalité une
contradiction là dedans et je pense que
rien personne ne craint vraiment ne peut
se faire d'illusion du fait que l'avenir
de l'Ukraine dans cette guerre va
dépendre de l'avenir du soutien des
États-Unis parce que les États-Unis sont
vraiment de très loin le plus grand
fournisseur d'armes à l'Ukraine merci
infiniment Gulliver Merci à VOUS Cyril
d'avoir participé à cette émission fin
de cette première partie on se retrouve
juste après le journal pour parler de
cette présidentielle du 25 février au
Nigeria la première puissance économique
d'Afrique à tout à l'heure
[Musique]